this weekend on Saturday was the White
House Correspondents Dinner and this
used to be just this little affair where
the the president you know some of the
media would get together and they'd rip
each other it has become like a bonkers
bonanza red carpet literally covered by
the e network we had celebrities like
psy Katy Perry duck dynasty I think both
Donald and Daffy were there yes I was
there uh and it's just become this
completely over-the-top big spectacle
and there's been a little blow back
against it because people are thinking
are saying you know should politics and
media and Hollywood be so intertwined uh
do you guys think that there's a danger
in having all our media so tight and
should the president always feel like a
celebrity jenkem sorry yeah so there's a
huge danger you know I've been in the
White House Correspondents Dinner I've
into the parties the brunches etcetera
etcetera and so I'm not be trying to be
a stickler here and say we shouldn't
have it but it should be the exception
it shouldn't be the rule like you should
be the one night when the watchdog's of
the government says hey you know what
let's go grab a burger together lets you
know and let's stop being so mean to the
government trying to find out what
they're doing in exposing it and tell
the American people cetera let's just
have a pleasant dinner together if that
was the exception to how they normally
operate great but it but it's the rule
it's really the five days are constantly
having cocktails together etc and
they're conspiring unwittingly in a
sense against us because what they're
supposed to deliver us is the truth is
the news the facts right but instead
what they're delivering us is you know
what the government wants us to hear
because they sold out for access so they
can go to the nerd prom yes so all right
so you come from the world of
entertainment and I see this in a
smaller way I think what happens in in
LA and in Hollywood is this is the same
exact thing you're never going to fight
against the power if you have an
artistic dream let's say to do something
great and different you're never going
to fight against the power if they're
inviting you to parties all the time
because you want to be liked to do you
see that as like a major problem when it
comes to politics and even just in
Hollywood itself well I mean we know
that
Media is I mean they report only what
they're told report anyway so I mean why
not have a big party together I think
it's important to get to know the
president on a social level it's just
times have changed now that we are so
interested in duck dynasty and honey boo
goose duck dynasty what is it I
literally don't know what is everyone's
dunst everyone show right now what is
its these guys that make these duck
calls they're just backwoods down-home
guys and one so it's not actually Daffy
and dumb like I swear I know but it just
it's a it's a show that I guess middle
America and southerners can really
relate I like how you're so dead roots
came out yeah you hear that coming out
right now it's one hundred percent
scripted if you watch the show it's
scripted by you know what should I got
that dynasty be sitting at the white as
far as hitters the thing yeah here's the
thing just in recent years is reality
stars the a-listers these days we want
to get to know them we'd want to know
their personal lives and that's what I
think people wanted to do with the
president now we want to know him and I
think it's great that we want to know
the president that well through his
Twitter accounts and all that type of
stuff I want to know what he's thinking
every single day I don't want to wait to
watch CNN or whatever to figure out what
he's doing the day I want to follow him
twenty-four/seven if i want to to keep
him in check and i think it's important
that the public gets that connection
with the president right well actually
let's speaking of getting to know the
president let's listen in a little bit
to what the president said at the white
house correspondents dinner and I think
you might get to know him a little bit
better but the problem is is that the
media landscape is changing so rapidly
you can't keep up with it i mean i
remember when buzzfeed was just
something i did in college around 2am
it's true okay so the line marries it's
true and this is what I love about this
because back in the Clinton days where I
didn't inhale look how far we've come
with that we all know you're lying to us
every single president has done probably
every major drug out there and way more
probably slept with guys all that kind
of stuff before everyone I mean is
definitely closed do this stuff that you
know most like yes now you know when you
have someone that just honestly being
like yeah okay obviously smoke weed in
college okay great then we know we're
not lied to you know at least we know
okay they're not trying to put up this
crazy front right so I'm with you on
that the part that I have a problem with
about this particular clip is that he's
talking about weed obviously we've all
smoked salmon terrible shoulder pain
coma but he is also using the federal
government right now to that has been
attacking here in California they've
been trying to close pot dispensaries
and they're putting people in jail still
for smoking weed there are people
literally serving 20 30 years sentences
not for selling weed for smoking weed so
is there a little bit of hypocrisy in
what the president in the game that he's
playing now there's a giant bit of
hypocrisy it relates to the Geoghan it
actually really saw Lance was saying
earlier as well so look I don't want to
be a party pooper and analyze every joke
and like you should set up yeah but at
the same time it's not funny when we
have millions of people in jail for the
same exact thing that brock obama and
george w bush have done have admitted to
doing so unless you're gonna put those
two guys in prison let the other guys go
you know and so by the nature the look
of this dinner they have to joke around
about actual policy in it and everybody
hated it when Bush said all where the
weapons of mass destruction are they
here are there there and that's a really
important and serious topic but so is
what people characterizes the new Jim
Crow you know imprisoning so
disproportionately so many
african-americans you got an
african-american president he gets a
joke around about it but he never paid
the consequences and he's great like you
said he's breaking a record in number of
raids against drug dispensaries which he
said he wouldn't do and that's
outrageous right all right so is it
ultimately at the end of the day is this
a net gain or a net loss that work that
we
learn about our politicians through
celebrity that they have to bring these
people in is this neck n because people
are the average person is now learning
something about politics so that's
pretty good and then on the other hand
they seem to be blurring this line
between truth and well I mean I
personally think that the more that we
can get this younger especially younger
generation more interested in politics
the better if it's using social media
and making him a reality star great
people like us that follow politics and
all that type of stuff we know what's
going on we get educated about it but
these other people that are only
watching honey boo boo they don't give a
crap about politics this is a way that
you can actually like the president and
like what he's doing maybe and figure
out what he's doing and related to duck
dynasty apparently yeah look I my only
concern about that is that they're not
getting an accurate picture I mean all
this so including his twitter account
etceteras heavily management right so
they're putting out a version of Barack
Obama that isn't necessarily there
obviously the real Obama it's a version
of it right and so if that's the only
image that people have of them it
they're not getting a true because if
they see that joke you think oh he's
cool he's cool he smoke weed and such
but they don't know that he's not that
cool with imprisoning millions of
people's for just for smoking weed right
so perhaps if when conan o'brien went on
after and had said well President Obama
you know you have jailed a lot of people
about weeded would have got like this
tepid laugh but a little truth would
have been in there instead Conan was
sort of making fun of Mitt Romney which
is just so easy at this point yeah
that's why Stephen Colbert had the
greatest White House Correspondents
Dinner routine in history could never be
topped I mean that's very famously said
uh you know reality has a well-known
liberal bias any the room if you
remember the room hated it yeah because
he went after the government he went
after the media and often it was like
total dead silence but it was it was
fantastic yeah which is why I always
tell you guys if you want truth in news
don't go to MSNBC or fox or CNN Young
Turks and Comedy Central that's right
okay
I want to remind you guys that the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
is bonobos go to bonobos com use code TR
are 20 and get yourself this fancy shirt